wir haben nichts an in unserem neuen
Garten gefrühstückt als ich diese
Pflanze entdeckt habe da sind bei mir
gleich die Alarmglocken angegangen
deswegen hieß es erstmal raus aus dem
Schlafanzug und rein in langärmelige
Anziehsachen denn das hier ist
Jakobskreuzkraut der Albtraum aller
Landwirte denn das Zeug ist hochgiftig
für beide Tiere und auch für Menschen
und ich will hier schließlich Schafe und
alle möglichen Bauernhof Tiere halten
dann ist mir aufgefallen dass der Spaten
noch gar nicht mit ins neue zu Hause
umgezogen ist also mussten wir aus dem
was wir gefunden haben einen zusammen
basteln und dann habe ich alle Pflanzen
mit Wurzelballen ausgegraben das reicht
immer noch nicht um dem Jakobskreuzkraut
den Garaus zu machen wenn ich das jetzt
einfach auf den Komposthaufen schmeiße
dann können sich die Pflanzen trotzdem
noch weiter ausbreiten also haben wir
alle Pflanzen den ganzen Abend lange im
Lagerfeuer geröstet damit die komplett
absterben drückt uns bitte die Daumen
dass wir jetzt unsere Ruhe davor haben
ich will nämlich unbedingt schaffen